Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wir stehen vor dem Salon und es beginnt schon zu winden. Es ist aber noch kein Herbst, sondern es ist Sommeranfang, es ist alles durcheinander.
Wie wird das Wetter wohl auf Sylt werden? Da findet ja die Hochzeit statt. Und du weißt, wer dort auch eine Rede halten wird?
Ich hab nur ein bisschen gehört, wer da ist. Habe oder eingeladen, weiß nicht, ob er kommt. Scholz ist natürlich da. Und eine Rede wird vielleicht Sloterdijk halten, das finde ich gut.
Sehr richtig. Ja. Das ist natürlich auch schlimm, wenn man als Philosoph in diese Tiefen hinabsteigt.
Ach du großer Gott. Was will er denn sagen da?
Vielleicht wiederholt er einfach noch mal seinen Essay von der gebenden und der nebenden Hand und dann bekommt Lindner noch mal gesagt, dass alles richtig ist, was er jetzt gerade tut.
Genau, es geht ja um die Eheschließung von Christian Lindner. Vielleicht liest er auch aus Zorn und Zeit.
Ach so.
Ist ja für ihn auch nicht ganz falsch. Die einen machen das Gelübde auf ewig und so und dann kommt er mit Zorn und Zeit. Wir sind ja, meine Damen und Herren. Wer weiß. Wir wünschen allen alles Gute, die es gebrauchen können und allen anderen viel Spaß auf so Happenings. Ich habe gesehen, auf Twitter kursieren schon die besten 9 Euro Zugverbindungen nach Süd.